the stone city of Machu Picchu is one of
the most fascinating archaeological
sites on the planet located northwest of
Cusco Peru Machu Picchu is a testament
to the power and ingenuity of the Inca
people during its prime the Inca
civilization stretched about 2,500 miles
along South America's Pacific coastline
from modern-day Ecuador down into Chile
this distance is nearly the horizontal
width of the continental United States
Machu Picchu located at the center of
this once expansive Empire is one of the
few well-preserved remnants of the Inca
civilization built around the mid 15th
century Machu Picchu is a stunning
example of the Incas engineering feats
the Inca constructed Machu Picchu spaces
temples terraces and infrastructure
using stone and without the help of
wheels or tools made of steel or iron
one particularly notable aspect of their
construction is forgoing the use of
mortar a material often used to bind
stones together nonetheless the stones
of Machu Picchu were cut so precisely
that they snugly fit together located on
two fault lines Machu Picchu often
experiences earthquakes but because of
the stones exceptional cut and fit they
bounce during tremors and then are able
to easily fall back into position these
engineering Marvel's have preserved
Machu Picchu remarkable condition for
over 500 years
Machu Picchu purpose is still a mystery
to many archeologists some theorize that
it may have served as a ceremonial site
a military stronghold or a retreat for
nobility the site's geographic layout
may be significant in another way many
of both the man-made and natural
structures appear to align with
astronomical events
but in the early sixteenth century only
about 100 years after it was built
Machu Picchu was abandoned and since the
Inca had no written language no records
exist to explain the exact purpose of
the site although local communities knew
about Machu Picchu the site remained
largely unknown to the outside world for
hundreds of years
Spanish conquistadors who invaded the
Inca civilization in the 16th century
never came across the site it wasn't
until the early 20th century when
Melchor art Yaga a local farmer debuted
Machu Picchu to outsiders when he led
Yale University professor Hiram Bingham
to the site Bingham and successive
explorers devoted much of their academic
careers to studying the archaeological
wonder
despite its enigmatic nature Machu
Picchu still stands as one of the
world's most important archeological
sites it is a testament to the power and
ingenuity of one of the largest empires
in the Americas in 1983 UNESCO
designated Machu Picchu as a world
heritage site and today visitors from
around the world come to pay homage to
this piece of history
[Music]
you